la parole est à notre collègue maltilde
Olivier pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Solidarités et de la
famille zéro enfant à la rue c'est ce
que vous prométiz il y a 1 an nous
sommes mi-novembre la trêve hivernale a
commencé le froid s'installe et pourtant
madame la ministre ce soir ce sont bien
2822 enfants qui dormiront dehors votre
politique de mise à la abri est donc un
échec pire votre bilan s'est alourdi
c'est 20 % d'enfants en plus qui vivent
dehors voilà la réalité l'hébergement
d'urgence relève de la responsabilité
première et principale de l'État mais
aujourd'hui c'est la solidarité
citoyenne qui compense vos failles
madame la ministre h écoles à Lyon se à
Rennes se à Paris deux à Grenoble ce
sont 30 écoles qui sont occupées la nuit
pour permettre aux enfants de dormir au
chaud à l'hôpital des femmes restent
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
pour ne pas repartir à la rue avec leur
nouveau-né nos mairres nos départements
nos députés sont en première ligne et se
mobilisent ils vous ont exprimé leur
impuissance face à cette situation nous
attendons depuis plusieurs semaines une
réaction du gouvernement il n'en est
rien vous avez choisi le camp du déni
nous vous avons demandé en urgence la
création de 10000 lieux d'hébergement en
plus à l'Assemblée nationale vous les
avez refusé et surtout ne me répondez
pas avec des excuses financière dans un
pays comme la France que représentent
10000 hébergements d'urgence en plus
face à des enfants des familles qui
dorment dans des écoles et qui vite le
matin doivent ranger les sacs de
couchage avant l'arrivée de leurs
copains que représentent ces budget si
c'est pour sauver des vies alors
qu'est-ce que cette banalisation des
enfants dans la rue dit de notre société
madame la ministre quand comptez-vous
annoncer l'augmentation des lieux
d'hébergement
d'urgence pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'enfance madame Charlotte
cobel merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les sénate
madame la sénatrice Mathilde Olivier
évidemment dans la semaine des droits de
l'enfant avoir un enfant à la rue c'est
évidemment un enfant de trop le droit à
des conditions dignes de vie est un
droit fondamental reconnu par la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant le Gouvernement partage
pleinement les préoccupations qui sont
les vôtres sur la situation de ses
enfants et de ses familles face à ces
situations dramatiques il prend
contrairement à ce que vous dites ses
responsabilités nous y avons encore été
attentif à l'occasion du dernier comité
interministériel de l'enfance les
efforts déployés pour mettre à l'abri
n'ont jamais été aussi importants comme
en témoigne le maintien du parc
d'hébergement d'urgence à un très haut
niveau depuis 2017 il y a eu constamment
de la création de plac de mise à l'abri
et nous avons maintenu un niveau de plus
de 200000 places ouvertes chaque année
qui permet d'héberger 70000 enfants vous
parlez de chiffres qui évoluent
constamment puisque des familles FAM
arrivve constamment nous plaçons nous
accueillons des familles et d'autres
familles arrivent c'est bien l'enjeu des
flux et vous parlez en stock madame des
mesures intégrées dans le PCT de
solidarité permettent de maintenir par
ailleurs l'amélioration des conditions
de vie de ces enfants l'année dernière
c'est plus de 3000 enfants qui ont été
récupérés pour être scolarisés par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
ces hébergements à l'hôtel nous veillons
à la scolarisation des enfants à l'accès
aux soins à la création de lieux
alimentaires et de lieux de loisirs pour
le améliorer leurs conditions de vie
mettre à l'abri ses enfants ne doit pas
nous nous nous faire perdre un objectif
principal qui est l'accès à un logement
péren et là aussi le gouvernement est
profondément engagé l'accès au logement
social a permis d'accueillir plus de
240000 personnes l'année dernière avec
100000 enfants donc on est bien dans une
logique de sortir ses enfants aussi du
logement d'urgence nous souhaitons et
c'est important conduire cette politique
volontariste avec les le secteur
associatif les collectivités
territoriales pour attribuer des
logements sociaux aux personnes sortant
d'hébergement c'est notre engagement je
vous remercie madame
Olivier en 2017 le président de la
République disait qu'il ne voulait plus
voir de personne à la rue en attendant
maintenant c'est 2800 enfants qui sont à
la rue vous êtes au responsabilités
depuis 6 ans vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur c'est votre politique qui amène
à cette catastrophe sociale ce n'est
plus l'heure de se défiler réveiller
d'héberementainten la parole est à notre
collèguene Valon pour le gros
[Applaudissements]
républicain